Sometimes just, dude,
sometimes people hang things.
They hang things in their
garage and the cold too.
So you mentioned were hanging
on I think about is Jesse some,
oh my God.
Talk about said No.
Whole bunch of people
back in one interview.
Crazy story itches. It
such a mess. It's a mess.
And I think was really awful about
it because his story, it was,
it was like good and bad of it to good
of it was when people thought that he was
violated and he was a victim of a
hate crime. It wasn't just gay people.
There was a Russian to support him.
It was like thug dudes,
you know what I'm saying? It was like
some real motherfuckers. Dell was like,
I mean, I saw exhibit, make a comment.
It was a community of people away from
the LBG community to thought it was
really fucked up. Yeah. And that's,
that was the beauty of the incident
because it kind of put people together.
But the fun thing about it was just a
lot and it's so fucking unfortunate.
It's so unfortunate.
Somebody would play on people's emotions.
Yeah.
For or to benefit
themselves. It's, it's awful.
Well this a certain narcissism that
exists in show business there. Thank you.
And I both know very well,
you know,
we've all seen it and thankfully the
people that seem to be the best for
whatever reason, they have the,
with some of the best handles on it.
Like Dave doesn't show any of that.
Right?
But there's some people that do and that
narcissism is weird that that wanting
it to be all about them and then they'll
do sneaky shit like faking attack.
Like that's, that's a symptom of
that same kind of thinking. It just,
it just got desperate and
went in some crazy way.
It was officer a reason
because you have people,
like when I first went down you had
people that normally people that you would
look at,
okay that's my friend or whoever you
started having side eyes and that's just,
it's just,
it's so messed up.
And I think also as messed up as much as
people wrote for him when they thought
that it was an injustice, everything,
nobody's really talking about it.
Nobody's addressing. They're like,
you know, this is our movement.
These are things that we were
trying to progress toward,
but this was an isolated incident
and just say how awful it was.
Yeah.
You know,
the beautiful thing is that people are
way more tolerant than they ever have
been before. They're also beautiful
things. Attack didn't happen. Right?
So I don't have to think of one more
atrocious thing that people have done to
another person for no reason.
All right? So that's good.
And it's also good that you get to see
where that kind of stuff heads where
you're always looking to be a victim to
the point where you realize there's like
some sort of currency and being a victim.
So people fake being a victim, right?
So they can get all this fucking
attention. It's good for us.
It's good for us to see. Cause you see
that now next time a story comes around,
that's just a little fishy. You
going to second guess it. Exactly.
It's like the boy who cried wolf.
And that's what's unfortunate about it
because anytime someone says that they
were a victim of such a heinous crime
like that, you want to believe them.
You want to believe them. I
mean they said, well this is,
it makes you start second guessing thing
and that's another thing that was awful
about the whole thing and all the smoke
he's getting right now and he deserved,
because I've been tearing his ass up
on Instagram on everything he did.
He deserves every bit of it. He knows he
deserves, everybody knows he deserves it.
I read,
I read a story once about this dude who
said that he punished his daughter by
making her sit in the backyard by a
tree and then he went out there an hour
later and she was gone and the suspect
that coyotes got her and I remember
thinking that story going, man,
that just does not sound real.
That does not sound real.
It just seems weird. Yeah,
you just kind of left a baby in
the backyard and coyotes got it.
Like reading was like a new, like not
walking or anything like that. Well,
he left the baby like to punish the baby,
like a two year old left it in the,
well, it turns out he really didn't
do that. The kid died and he,
he'd stuffed it in some drainage
ditch somewhere. So this, uh,
I don't remember how the kid died.
What was the reason for it?
But it was one of those stories
where you hear the story like, Jesus,
it doesn't sound real.
Sometimes stories don't sound real.
The next thing we're going to be
second guessing everything. I hope not.
But when it first went down,
I thought it was a,
I've thought it was a situation where
Lee Daniels and Jesse sat down in a
writer's room and Lee
Daniels, Lee, anybody got any
ideas for any new episodes?
It just like, I got one. Nobody's
going to believe it. Look,
I'm going to be hungry and shit.
Right?
I'm going to go to subway to get a 12
inch footlong elite. Dan, who's like,
I believe that.
I believe that part day with her, the
whole story elite. Danny said some,
nobody's going to believe it. Jesse
got upset. It told the totally dance.
We'll see.
I'm going to shoot him myself,
and he walked to into that whole
scenario and it's just awful.
That's entirely possible. That's
what it sounds like. It sounds like.
Now you're gonna say now anybody
that was a fan of empire,
which I know a lot of people that are
listening, we're being very sarcastic.
When I say that,
they're going to be like second guessed.
The storylines of so many of those shows,
the storylines of everybody,
whoever's said today,
we're done wrong or anything.
The awful thing about this is now people
are going to be ready and quick to just
second guessed anything that you say.